hey i think
today we're checking out some cringy
videos my dog maya hates cringy videos
so she has compiled a list for us my
sisters thought this waiter was cute so
my dad did this
my daughters think that
[Laughter]
why do parents get a kick out of this
and i know i'll do the same if i become
a dad
am i embarrassing you maya
you want to hide under the table
it's so mean
but also hilarious hey how you doing can
you shut the [ __ ] up
hey
how are you
you want to try these donuts down so no
[ __ ] i'm gonna die hi how are you good
how are you on a good old diet
two packs of chips is that it is that it
is that it that it give me a damn man
would you like a receipt yes
ma'am your receipt
[Music]
[Laughter]
apparently
195
you can insert it there
excuse me
i just ran out of gas and i ain't got no
money
well give a [ __ ]
oh it is america it's kind of it's it's
weirdly wholesome is that weird to
saying can you shut the [ __ ] up they
remind me of sapphire characters oh yeah
in the movie all the happy people stop
and say hello get out of my face even
though the temperature is the perfect
one i love that movie i feel like it
feels it's not wholesome obviously but
it feels wholesome because everyone is
in on it everyone is just
decided to be an [ __ ] all right i
need more cringe so someone asked who
has custody
[Music]
three days and three days off what
mommy's about to tell you is not gonna
be easy but your father and i are
getting a divorce
so here's how that's gonna go down
it's a 50 50
custody
split
that means
monday
wednesday
friday
good
thank you it always bothered me like why
are you dancing you don't have to dance
are people incapable of watching tick
tock unless people dance do i have to
dance now in all my videos
so you guys keep attention
this is what i gotta do huh for you to
smash like on this video
all right maya will do it
sorry maya
before we continue quick word from
sponsor taking this moment to introduce
the bloody pie shaker it's inspired by
the ocean it's inspired by sweden it's
inspired by
blue and me
one of the best looking shakers we got
baby look at that it's now available for
pre-order these things usually go fast
so make sure you sign up for it and you
will be notified first on securing one
of these bad boys your life will improve
significantly at least half a percent
what do you got the liz
don't forget to add code pewdiepie as
always for epic discount and grab a tub
of pewdiepie flavor because it's on sale
buy one get one for free this is during
g fuel's christmas during july sale
oh yeah great shaker great energy drink
love it
uh meet larry who airdropped a whole
flight photos obviously
thankfully i accepted it thought
what do you mean thankfully
connoisseurs but okay and immediately
started speaking up
stay tuned for the police escort
[Music]
damn he's owning up dude
i did i am the one sending the photos of
my wiener
i understand i apologize
what did you think was gonna happen
you're on a flight you can't go anywhere
idiot i mean don't do it in general but
still
this is me i'm sorry were you with
anyone last night no i wasn't yeah
[Music]
this can't be real
mandy not just drew that on his face it
has to be comedy right
it's tick tock i
i don't know the line
the line is so blurred maya what do you
think is it cringe
it's cringe
what's that
oh it's cringe she confirmed it wall
cleaning update my landlord cleaning
update and he's filming
um my wall because he doesn't think i'm
doing a good enough job cleaning it
he was also mad because there was a hole
in the wall but i clearly covered it i
fixed it
the door is clean
this just needs like another one over
and like all that gray will be gone
cause we have porous walls so what
you're seeing is the crayons stuck
inside of the little holes he said i
could have 30 days
you said 30 days yeah i did but i got to
make sure you're working on it
you can go now
i'm putting this on tick tock
oh please oh please madam don't put this
on tick tock whatever will i do
oh god not the tick tock the [ __ ] is
this
why she had a bread guys
wall update
bro just paint it you're gonna lose your
deposit anyway [ __ ] japanese
as living in japan can 100 confirm
pov you had a heart attack you had a
heart attack
[Laughter]
that man saw his moment and took it
ninety percent oh so you think you did
it on purpose yeah probably that's
[ __ ] creepy as hell dude
yeah he did
[Laughter]
these awful movements women can do that
men can't you grab a broomstick bend
down and simply step over it but when
men try to perform the same movement
they simply can't
man we should try this that's a joke
right please step over it but when men
try to perform with straight legs you
grab a broomstick bend down and simply
step over it but when men try to perform
the same movement
what
[Music]
what's the problem
they simply can't you step two feet away
from the wall bend over press your head
against the wall lift your chair up to
your chest and then stand back up but
when guys try and do the same thing
something about our center of gravity
stops us from doing the standing up part
[Music]
all right apparently you can just say
[ __ ] on the tic-tac and people believe
it what the [ __ ] uh speaking in a baby
voice to my friends
to my friends and seeing if they do it
back
hi johnny
hi
how you doing
how are you
what are you doing right now
i'm just like the gym right now
i miss you
i miss you too did you have a good
workout
i gotta try that what would you do if
you saw me at the red light
and i hunk my horn at you
and we made eye contact and i said to
you
hell
what's up baby girl yo [ __ ] creep
dude jesus christ people getting
ah
woman don't like this or man
where do these deep kids get this level
of confidence from yes what the [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] god i
i can't be the only one with the opinion
that it's kind of uncomfortable seeing
these type of tick tocks
where
they they play some sad music and then
[Music]
what
it looks
like fine but then you think that she
put the camera there
she staged it she reenacted it
it's just funny
it's weird i get that being a doctor is
extremely stressful and maybe
talking to people about it is a way to
cope it tick tock should not be the
vessel man what do you think he's doing
what do you think he's working
gross
i don't know either yes biceps what he's
working his biceps he's doing what's
called yeah
now granted most people do them with a
barbell he's doing them with dumbbells
so it may look a little strange a little
awkward but it is a great movement the
point of it is as you kick your elbows
back and drag up along your body you're
taking stress off the deltoid putting it
all on the bicep it's actually a great
workout charles glass who's one of the
best there is is a big promoter of this
exercise but what's most important what
he's doing and working most of all is
minding his own business the fact that
people at the gym take videos of other
people to try and make fun of them blows
my mind be better than that yeah mind
your own [ __ ] business why do you
film people at the gym i mean i
definitely like
people like the gym now think about it
well that's people that have no clue
what the [ __ ] they're doing instead of
just asking someone
[Music]
this is ken already
[Music]
[Laughter]
the khakis tucked
[Laughter]
ken would love this
i gotta set it too
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right that's enough for today that
was fun hope you guys enjoyed as well
i am sleeping now so i will not disturb
her but uh she says thanks for smashing
like and subscribe see you in the next
video